you're gonna you're you're gonna die you
weren't there
hooting the blowfish oh wow derek do it
right
rucker he's his country yeah what a
great guy he's a fan that's awesome how
about brian do you know what songs he's
saying
i i i love he's such a good guy but i
didn't know he was i don't know he was
so big does he have money
uh uh dearest no your brother said your
brother said he's
so rich he's one of my favorites i go
who what do you mean because i thought i
was slow
i thought it was hootie i went like this
one i didn't see you over there brother
yeah i i he's such a nice guy but i
didn't realize how
and then i turned it anyway don't think
about it
do you know you don't know his jam no we
playing we're getting demonetized
but he's a big deal i guess i mean he's
got a grammy award-winning he's still
crushing it
wow and and i said a joke and it didn't
go well
and you didn't hear it i went hey
dearest he said he's leaving it the
dolphins make me cry too
and i stood there like this and he went
cool man i went it's from your song
yes i know but i'm gonna leave now that
was the last time i talked to him yeah
he can't he watched us he loved it he
loved our show
yeah yep really cool really cool guy
there oh he has some [ __ ] hits well i
guess he's still
i only want to be with you is the
dolphins make me cry yeah
he can write and then he went later blow
fish
and start doing country what a story is
that
his eyes for a second let her cry his
eyes he might have he might
he might have gotten the brian kellen
special well
you're gonna get the hootie special
because he did it before you're right
and yours is still to be determined
bubba
um oh he looks good
hell of a golfer too make a call right
now i don't think
he might have gotten brian's brian's
lips i don't think so
good nose on him
he's a handsome fella and a very
talented man
plays golf five days a week oh wait
let's go back
go back to hootie do they still play
sometimes who did the blowfish
that drummer right there used to always
play with his shirt off and i had a huge
problem with it
well you stop now because they're both
like you've got to stop yeah how old did
he say
when he's younger remember you guys were
comparing he said he's 51. he's 50 i
think
yeah i don't know he's so talented he
was on this season of america and i
don't want to talk to him about it oh he
won't get an opportunity to
why there's a lot of people in the room
my dolphins joke bombs
he has so many hits god however rider
do you wish you were there now jen it
would have been pretty dope to meet him
you guys could talk music yeah
oh uh stevie post a picture with him yes
and him god get your
costume balls out of my face bro
um i don't see one
maybe just took it posted later maybe
chappelle posted it one of the guys or
malik might have posted too that's a
picture of me and
man oh gorilla oh look at you with your
eyes closed though
yeah that picture makes no sense you
know okay grillo look at how rugged
grillo looks just a tough
dude yes he's just a tough father he
looks like he's been up for seven nights
in a row but whatever he's just
he doesn't sleep he sleeps five hours a
night he's the only person i've ever
seen he can live well there's a lot of
five hours four hours
he's incredible i've never seen him like
it he just doesn't need sleep
there's a few guys like that i'm gonna
tell you this right now yeah
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue okay
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
oh she was [ __ ] disrespected